the Joe Rogan experience I'd like to
make you work moving of I don't that
movie you don't know the year of the
dragon back would make you work before
you went crazy
alright it's [ __ ] great I'm a young
Mickey Rourke I'm Mickey Rourke and old
there's two different humans young
Mickey Rourke in ol Mickey Rourke young
Mickey Rourke was like this like super
serious amazing actor did fantastic
films like really good that yeah angel
heart well so what had died first so
didn't he get like in a motorcycle
accident and bonk his head is that what
happened here is over the edge yeah
here's a trailer of it no he became a
boxer he boxed as an amateur when he was
young and then when he was an actor I
think if I had to guess and I'm gonna
just paraphrase and I apologize if I got
it wrong but I think he felt like
Hollywood and acting and I know he's
quote he's been quoted on this was so
fake and so with lack of a better term
feminine it was it was so it was so soft
and [ __ ] that he felt like he had to
do something real again so he started
boxing again as a world famous movie
star I got but I got punchy he started
sparring with James Toney and a bunch of
other guys a bunch of legit boxers and
from when I heard James Toney used to
just touch him up every day and of
course you don't want to be that guy who
can't hang so he's in there taking
[ __ ] jabs to the face and right hands
to the face and left hooks to the face
and uppercuts to the face and his face
got deformed and then he wound up
getting like cheek implants and a bunch
of weird [ __ ] right you got a bunch of
weird facial surgery and stuff and I
don't you know they start losing his
mind but I think CTE played a factor
there I think just I think there's a to
me it's a logical correlation so like
here's a guy who's this world-famous
amazing movie star the nine and a half
weeks and all these other big-time
movies me saw a [ __ ] blockbuster
movie stuff and an interesting movie
star like a really good actor and then
all of a sudden he becomes this crazy
guy and in between them he's getting
punched in the face a bunch of times
like it doesn't take a genius right to
make these connections right I know a
lot of
that were pretty normal when they were
young and then somewhere into their MMA
career they lost it and they went off
the rails there's a there's a growing
list of those guys growing yes yeah and
some gals are on that list as well okay
yeah
so it's uh it's the gals are there's as
they as Ronda Rousey's opened up the
door for women's MMA to become more
popular that's gonna be more and more
women that are taking more punishment
including ones that you're never going
to see inside the USA just and the other
thing is that just training if you just
decide I just I don't want to fight but
I want to train well that counts